So now you can see,
if only we'd used Index On and Value,
Grocery Grabber's corporate
takeover would have never happened.
So let's take a look at how they work.
Index On tells Firebase which child
keys your app uses in queries.
A notes key is indexed automatically, so
there is no need to
index them explicitly.
Using index on is optional, but it
will dramatically improve performance.
You can use index on in conjunction
with order by child to optimize queries.
In this example, you assign a rule to
the children you want to optimize on.
You can use index on
with order by value.
Which will optimize
queries on a value rule.
>> Intrude in sector one.
>> They've discovered us on the network,
I can't close the connection.
[SOUND]